how are you able to find work-life
balance is there advice you can give
maybe even outside yourself have you
been able to arrive at any wisdom on
this
part in your years of life i do think
that there's a wide range of people
where different people have different
needs it's not a one-size-fits-all i am
certainly what works for me i i can tell
enough that
i'm you know i'm different than a
typical average person and the way
things impact me the you know the things
that i want to do my goals are different
and sort of the levers to impact things
are different where
you know i've literally never felt
burnout and i know there's lots of
brilliant smart people that that do
world-leading work that get burned out
and it's never hit me i'm you know i've
never been at a point where i'm like i'm
i just don't care about this i don't
want to do this anymore but i've always
had the flexibility to work on lots of
interesting things you know i can always
just turn my gaze to something else and
have a great time working on that and so
much of that and so much of the ability
to actually work hard is the ability to
have multiple things to choose from and
to use use your time on the most
appropriate thing like there are there
are time periods where i am it's the
best time for me to read a new research
paper that i need to really be thinking
you know hard about it then there's a
time that maybe i should just scan and
organize my old notes because my you
know i'm just not on top of things then
there's the time that all right let's go
you know bang out a few hundred lines of
code for something
so switching between them
has been real valuable
so you'll always have kind of joy in
your heart for all the things you're
doing and that that is the kind of
work-life balance that's the first sort
of step yeah i do you're always happy i
do
yeah i'm happy yeah i mean it's like i a
lot of people would say that often i
look like kind of a grim person you know
with just sitting there with a neutral
expression or even like knitted brows
and a frown on my face as i'm staring at
something that's what happens it looks
like for you yeah
it's it's kind of true or that that's
like okay i'm pushing through this i'm
making progress here i am you know i
know that doesn't work for everyone i
know it doesn't work for most people i
am
but what i am always trying to do in
those cases is i don't want to let
somebody that might be a person like
that be told by someone else that no
don't try it don't even try that out as
an option where
i you know work life
balance versus kind of your life's work
where there's a small subset of the
people that can be very happy
being obsessive about things and you
know obsession can often get things done
that just practical prudent pedestrian
work won't or at least won't for a very
long time
you